you know those amber alerts you get on
your phone every once in a while and I'm
not talking about the color of Donald
Trump's skin I don't mean an Amber Alert
means Trump's coming to your town I mean
those amber alerts on your phone where
there's a loud alarm and your phone
tells you there's either a car you're
supposed to keep an eye out for or
there's you know an abducted child or a
criminal that's on the loose or
something like that this relates to
Hurricane Harvey as well as the FCC the
FCC has been wanting to update the
system of these Amber Alerts so that you
could send out pictures or videos or
maps multimedia of different kinds and
also send out alerts in different
languages or to be able to
geographically fine-tune who receives
these Amber Alerts and many local
governments have been pushing for these
improvements but there's been pushback
from mobile carriers and this includes
AT&T Sprint Verizon t-mobile sort of the
usual suspects and these service
providers have been saying that these
types of updates would be overly
burdensome for us that it would be
technically challenging to implement or
it might be too costly to put in place
or it would congest the network's
because of course they need the
bandwidth to allow those robo calls
about car insurance to go through and
the disagreements of excuse me about
this between regulators in the mobile
industry have have sort of escalated
quite a bit in the last few months and
mobile carriers have been more and more
vocally opposed to improving improving
the amber alert system in this way and
this is at a sort of an interesting
moment in this debate because we're
seeing catastrophic weather in Texas
right now with hurricane Harvey we've
seen a series of disasters that have
taken lives and destroyed a lot of
property in the United States and people
in the middle of these crises would
definitely benefit from an improved and
centralized system for getting
information out there right this would
be before these disasters during the
disasters and after the disasters as
well last month
emergency preparedness officials in
Harris County Texas publicly criticized
mobile providers
being reluctant to go along with these
FCC changes and Harris County happens to
be one of the counties most affected by
hurricane Harvey flooding and this was
before we even knew about hurricane
Harvey specifically we knew that this
was a a county at particular risk of
flooding in general and we now have a
situation where these specific types of
improvements to the AMBER Alert System
could have helped get people out of
harm's way from hurricane Harvey could
it have prevented as of right now we
know about five deaths could could those
any of those have been prevented by the
system I don't know but it doesn't
really matter this is exactly one of
these situations where we have huge and
hugely profitable companies like our
wireless carriers saying it's too much
for us we can't really do it and when
you look at the profits of these
companies who believes that they can't
afford this who believes that the
implementation of such an improved
system would be overly burdensome for
them it is absolutely and completely not
believable and this isn't actually the
first time that this type of thing has
happened in the early 20th century in
San Francisco San Francisco had the
opportunity to improve their water
system to include a sort of emergency
response system think of sort of fire
hydrants all over towns and cities today
so that when there's a fire you can
actually hook up a hose in multiple
locations by using a fire hydrant and
put out the fire the San Francisco City
Council voted against upgrading their
fire prevention or suppression system in
the early 20th century then there was
the great San Francisco earthquake and
subsequent fires that happened after
that vote and the city burned to the
ground because of an adequate fire
response so this stuff matters and we
often talk about improving our
infrastructure and emergency
preparedness in this distant and
disconnected way like yeah that'd be
nice because some hypothetical people we
don't know might be affected by that the
debate has been going on for the last
several months about this Amber Alert
System and right now in Texas people are
being affected by
a lot of people don't know about this
story I think it's an important story to
cover send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program made possible in part by
policy genius life insurance can be
pretty confusing it can be time
confusing and if there is even a payout
you won't be around to spend it but
there is a company that's making this
all a lot easier it's policy genius.com
which is the place to go to learn about
life insurance you can also compare
quotes from the top life insurance
providers and you can save up to 40% off
of your policy they've got a simple
user-friendly website helps you figure
out exactly which policy is right for
you and it also finds you the best price
which is an important part of this
entire endeavor and if you've got
questions they have a team of licensed
experts waiting to talk you through it
no call waiting no pressing a ton of
buttons to direct your call you actually
get real customer service and they don't
just do life insurance you can also do
health insurance get insurance for your
pet even protect your income whatever it
is that you need so if you've been
putting this off if you want to make
sure you have the right insurance check
out policy genius.com today save up to
40% just by comparing policies the
quotes are free no sales pressure zero
hassle policy genius.com it's life
insurance for the 21st century